[Musik]
etwa drei millionen deutsch türken leben
in deutschland nach dem putschversuch
2016 in der türkei sind sie immer mehr
entzweit
in erdogan befürworter die den
präsidenten verehren und in erdogan
gegner
viele der gegner fühlen sich bedroht
überall dort wo viele türken sind fühle
ich mich nicht sicher viele erdogan
kritiker werden auch in deutschland
ausspioniert zum beispiel durch imame in
den etwa 900 moscheen des türkisch
muslimischen dachverbandes ditib direkt
an die botschaft
wolfhagen bei kassel an diesem bahnhof
gibt es eine moschee in die alina öl
salz keinen fuß mehr setzt vor
anderthalb jahren ist der 18 jährige mit
seiner familie nach deutschland geflohen
ihnen drohte in der türkei die
verhaftung denn sie sind anhänger des
predigers kühlen den erdogan für den
putschversuch verantwortlich macht
letzten august passierte hier etwas dass
alina in deutschland nicht für möglich
gehalten hätte der imam bespitzelte ihm
[Musik]
ein paar fragen gestellt
ich weiß nicht was er vor hat aber ich
habe einfach gesagt sprung aus der
türkei deswegen politischen sachen alina
erzählte so offen weil er darauf
vertraute in deutschland sicher zu sein
doch der mann drohte ihm
wenn du hierher kommst dann soll ich
mich die typische roger meldet das ist
meine verantwortung verpflichtung hatte
gesagt ja ich habe danach gesagt gut
dann komm ich mal wieder hier ja also
ich hab keine ahnung was der post und er
möchte mir noch mehr erzählen bricht
aber ab während unseres interviews sieht
er auf einmal den imam in der tür stehen
und bekommt angst
plötzlich taucht hinter uns ein
schwarzer porsche auf erkennt den fahrer
als ein weiteres mitglied der
moscheegemeinde der man warte zunächst
auf uns fährt aber weiter als er unsere
kamera sieht warum alles so ängstlich
reagiert wird klar als er von einem
weiteren vorfall erzählt wenige tage
nach der begegnung mit dem imam er ist
gerade auf dem weg nach hause wird sein
bus von mehreren männern gestoppt sie
fordern deshalb auf auszusteigen
doch viele fragen und ich habe einfach
ich gehe jetzt nach hause was aber ich
konnte nicht aus leider nicht
aussprechen
und dann kommen die fäuste treffen
[Musik]
zwei männer hätten ihn festgehalten
erzählt er
ein dritter zugeschlagen für aline als
familie ein schock ihr asylantrag wurde
anerkannt
sie haben sich hier in kurzer zeit ein
leben aufgebaut haben noch ein baby
bekommen
der vater hat heute einen sprachkurs
bestanden sie hofften eigentlich sie
könnten jetzt in deutschland frei leben
ohne angst
ich hätte so etwas nicht erwartet
deswegen sind wir hier hergekommen wie
dachte mir ist jeder in sicherheit
niemand kann dem anderen etwas tun
ich verstehe es einfach nicht vom imam
bespitzelt von gemeindemitgliedern
verprügelt als familie hat anzeige
erstattet bei der staatsanwaltschaft in
kassel ermittelt die abteilung für
staatsschutz wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung
der verdacht dass die straftat
möglicherweise politisch motiviert sein
könnte der ist nicht fernliegend und und
der ermittlungen besteht der anfängliche
verdacht gegen eine konkrete person
nämlich einen 45 jährigen mann aus dem
landkreis in kassel
der mann ist deutscher staatsangehöriger
hat aber eine türkische wurzeln
die moschee in wolfhagen wurde mit
geldern des landes hessen gefördert die
mitglieder der gemeinde gelten als
mustergültig integriert der
hauptverdächtige der zugeschlagen haben
soll ist geschäftsführer eines
unternehmens und stadtverordneter bei
der einweihung war auch der
bürgermeister mit dabei von uns erfährt
er von der spitzelei durch den imam und
die gewalt gegen den flüchtlingsjungen
vor abschluss der ermittlungen will er
sich nur vorsichtig äußern
das wäre herber rückschritt in der
zusammenarbeit in dem was wir gemeinsam
wollen das wären nach sieber bruch und
wenn sich das bestätigen sollte da
müssen wir darüber nachdenken welche
konsequenzen das hat aber es wird welche
haben ganz sicher über lange zeit haben
wir versucht auch mit dem moscheeverein
zu sprechen heute ist freitagsgebet
niemand öffnet uns trotz geöffneter
fenster
stattdessen erhalten wir eine nachricht
sehr geehrte frau müller es besteht kein
interesse unsererseits danke wir als
verein weisen sie darauf hin dass der
verein in ihren berichten nicht erwähnt
werden darf
erhalten die tib imame wirklich
anweisungen informationen über erdogan
kritiker weiterzugeben
wir fragen bei der türkischen botschaft
in berlin nach die antwort bekommen wir
nur schriftlich es ist nicht aufgabe der
türkischen botschaft informationen über
personen zu sammeln
der dachverband ditib selbst gibt
einzelfälle in der vergangenheit zu
einzelfälle diesbezüglich wurden von uns
entschieden verurteilt und die
protagonisten haben auf unser verlangen
deutschland verlassen wir fahren nach
weilheim in oberbayern
hier treffen wir einen renommierten
geheimdienstexperten erich schmidt
eenboom forscht seit rund 30 jahren zum
türkischen geheimdienst trifft sich
regelmäßig mit mitarbeitern des
deutschen verfassungsschutzes
er berichtet dass der verfassungsschutz
davon ausgehe dass die tib imame in
deutschland weiterhin spitzeln und
melden sind nachrichtendienstliche
zuträger die melden direkt an die
botschaften die informationen oder die
konsulate in deutschland seien rund ein
dutzend mitarbeiter des türkischen
geheimdienstes mit offiziell gemeldet so
der experte
doch es gebe auch viele inoffizielle
spitzel die ebenfalls hauptamtlich dort
arbeiteten die in der bundesrepublik
deutschland als agenten führer fungieren
und in die vielzahl von agenten ansätzen
die sie platzieren in bangenden
reisebüros in moscheevereinen und die
verfassungsschutzbehörden kommt auf die
gigantische menge von fast 8.000
zuträgern das ist im vergleich zu allen
anderen ausländischen
nachrichtendiensten eine gigantische
diese zahl bestätigt auch das bundesamt
für verfassungsschutz in seinem bericht
weiter heißt es zum türkischen
geheimdienst das aufklärungsinteresse
des mit in deutschland gilt
grundsätzlich allen organisationen und
einzelpersonen die in tatsächliche oder
mutmaßliche opposition zur gegenwärtigen
türkischen regierung stehen zu den
vorrangigen zielen gehöre derzeit auch
die gülen-bewegung welcher die
verantwortung für den gescheiterten
putsch 2016 zugeschrieben wird
wir wollen herausfinden wie der
türkische geheimdienst arbeitet und
waren nach süddeutschland
hier gelingt es uns einen ehemaligen
inoffiziellen spitzel zu treffen er kann
ausland wie er sich nennt war lange
selbst mitglied in erdogan kritischen
gruppen und er war spielsüchtig leichte
beute für den mit er wechselte die
seiten
sie suchen schwache leute die probleme
haben die politisch aktiv waren
die dann aufgehört haben wenn dann geld
im spiel ist dann machst du mit und
damals habe ich auch geld gebraucht ich
habe gedacht da machst du mit wie im
film james bond spiel obwohl das war
nicht so
der mit habe seine politischen kontakte
genutzt sagt er kann aslan um kurden
linke und andere oppositionelle zu
bespitzeln
entweder auf demonstrationen oder im
verein dann redest du mit den leuten
dann fragst du was gibt es nächste woche
was macht ihr so ein paar informationen
einholen
vier jahre lang zwei bis dreimal die
woche berichtete er über einen
mittelsmann nach ankara
wir haben uns immer draußen getroffen
teure restaurants die sich keine
ausländer leisten kann
ich habe ihm die informationen gegeben
und er hat mich bezahlt kommt darauf an
was für eine information dann bekommst
du so viel
und wer bereit sei weiter zu gehen
bekommen noch mehr ein bekannter von
erhan aslan in der schweiz habe erst vor
kurzem ein ganz besonderes angebot
bekommen sie wollten einen gülen
mitglied entführen und sie haben eben
gesagt sie bezahlen ihm dafür 100.000
franken
aber diese person hat es nicht
akzeptiert
heute will er mit dem türkischen mit
nichts mehr zu tun haben er lebt als
einfacher handwerker unerkannt in berlin
treffen wir heiko bader der
türkisch-armenische journalist und
kabarettist ist überzeugt dass vor vier
jahren ein mordanschlag auf ihn geplant
war
er ist immer noch wachsam wenn er auf
die straße geht der 44-jährige
kritisiert die regierung erdogan immer
wieder scharf nach dem putschversuch in
der türkei im sommer 2016 floh er nach
deutschland in der türkei wäre er längst
im gefängnis
in berlin fühlte sich heike barth am
anfang sicher bis ihn eines tages ein
türkischer journalist anrief den er für
sehr glaubwürdig hält er teilte mir mit
dass sich drei verschiedene teams aus
der türkei auf den weg gemacht hätten um
mich zu töten
er sagte auch dass er befürchtet habe
dass sein anruf zu spät kommen
ich habe sofort meinen anwalt angerufen
und wir sind zur polizei gegangen
die beamten haben uns sehr lang
vernommen und sie haben uns viele fragen
gestellt
ein paar tage später riefen sie uns an
wir sollten noch mal vorbeikommen sieben
bis acht leute waren bei den treffen
beamte des landeskriminalamtes und
mitarbeiter des deutschen
nachrichtendienstes
sie haben uns schließlich gesagt dass
unsere informationen stimmen
geheimdienstliche quellen eines anderen
landes hätten sie bestätigt wer genau
hinter den morddrohungen aus der türkei
steckt wollten ihm die deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden nicht sagen aber die
bedrohung nahmen sie sehr ernst
heiko bott bekam einen gepanzerten wagen
gestellt und ging ein jahr lang nur noch
in begleitung von personenschützern aus
dem haus sie waren lange zeit auch bei
seinen auftritten als kabarettist in
berlin dabei die machte er nur noch mit
schusssicherer weste
noch heute steht mehrmals am tag ein
polizeiauto vor seinem haus überall dort
wo viele türken sind fühle ich mich
nicht sicher
egal ob es beim sprachkurs oder in
türkischen supermärkten türkische
regierungskritiker die in deutschland
ermordet werden sollen
auf der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
wird auch der türkische außenminister
erwartet wir versuchen uns mit ihm für
ein interview zu verabreden
doch als der pressesprecher unser thema
hört sind die beiden für uns nicht mehr
zu erreichen
auf dem offiziellen pressetermin dürfen
wir nur eine frage stellen wollen von
den außenministern wissen was sie dazu
sagen dass erdogan gegner in deutschland
bespitzelt und bedroht werden
das ist eine reine komplott theorie das
hat mit der wahrheit nichts zu tun
es gibt natürlich unterstützer der pkk
in deutschland haben hier 3,5 millionen
bürger wenn sie sich als presse nicht
nur sorgen um die rechte bestimmte
terroristischer gruppen sondern auch um
die unserer bürger machen würden denke
ich wäre das viel besser und wie sieht
das der deutsche außenminister in der
letzten zeit in rechtsfragen zwischen
der türkei und in deutschland immer
wieder meinungsunterschiede und
grundsätzlich wird es so sein dass die
menschen in deutschland leben sich
natürlich auch auf die deutsche
rechtsordnung
diese rechte zur verfügung stehen und
sie auch geld
2017 war heiko maas noch
bundesjustizminister damals kam heraus
dass 19 die tib imame güllen anhänger
ausspioniert und nach ankara gemeldet
hatten ankara gab das sogar zu trotzdem
wurden die imame nicht strafrechtlich
belangt der generalbundesanwalt hat uns
dazu mit alle ermittlungsverfahren
wurden eingestellt bei einem teil der
beschuldigten wegen unbekannten
aufenthalts jahrelang in deutschland
aktiv war auch diese türkisch
nationalistischen rockergruppe
[Musik]
erst 2018 wurde die gewalttätige
gruppierung mit verbindungen zur
türkischen regierung vom innenminister
verboten nachdem sie jahrelang türkische
regierungsgegner bedroht angegriffen und
sogar kriegswaffen nach deutschland
geschmuggelt hatte rockergruppen kann
man verbieten aber wie geht man mit
kleinen oft anonymen spitzeln um der
kurde rgq so ist sich sicher dass er
denunziert wurde
wir treffen den städtischen mitarbeiter
in winnenden seit 28 jahren lebt er in
deutschland
vor einigen monaten hat der 48-jährige
erfahren dass in der türkei ein
haftbefehl gegen ihn vorliegt
al-ko so ist ein kritiker der regierung
erdogan und sagt offen seine meinung in
sozialen netzwerken
das ja nicht überall auf wo jemand mich
angezeigt hat ich weiß ganz genau dass
hierzu kein nicht einreisen kann
und wissen sie wer sie angezeigt weil
das weiß ich nicht das kann ich mich zu
100 prozent zusage und was bedeutet es
für sie wenn sie jetzt nicht mehr die
türkei einreisen kann die austria mutter
wenn meine mutter gestorben und
irgendwas passiert oft nicht nach türkei
anreise war wenig türkei gewesen dann
spare sie mich sofort das weiß sie ganz
genau der kuh so ist vor allem auf
facebook und twitter aktiv
er schreibt oft kommentare zur
türkischen politik und den vielen
gerichtsprozessen
wie zu diesem artikel in dem eine
umweltschützerin als terroristen
bezeichnet wird
[Musik]
darko so erfuhr von dem haftbefehl gegen
ihn rein zufällig als er wegen eines
dokuments das türkische generalkonsulat
in stuttgart aufsuchen musste und dort
einen mitarbeiter seinen pass übergab
[Musik]
angeguckt nicht ja dann 500 es später zu
mir gesagt du deine reisepass muss hier
bleiben wir beschlagnahme ist das weil
wir gegen die verletzung gewundert
in der türkei haben was wissen sie das
haupt zu mir gesagt weil sie nicht
später fand er heraus dass er wegen
beleidigung des präsidenten erdogan
angezeigt worden war
derzeit kann und seine frau fühlen sich
in deutschland sicherer als in der
türkei nur diese türkischstämmigen
verräter sagt er dazu so würden ihnen
das leben schwer machen
in münchen treffen wir im türkischen
generalkonsulat einen mann der hier als
vertrauensanwalt arbeitet er sagt
wiederum dass man alles tun müsse um der
türkischen justiz auch in deutschland zu
helfen
nadal altuntas gilt als initiator einer
umstrittenen smartphone app mit der
regierungskritiker bei der türkischen
polizei denunziert werden können
jeder staat hat ein legitimes
berechtigtes interesse der
strafverfolgung ja und um diese
strafverfolgungsbehörden auch zu
entlasten muss man schauen dass die dann
nicht jedes mal zur polizei gehen müssen
das ja auch eine personelle frage und so
hat jeder die möglichkeit hat gehe ich
da drauf und da können sie von
fahrraddiebstahl bis terrorismus alles
melden
sie kamen ja hier auch ein eigenes bild
aufnehmen und das schicken sie und
dadurch dass das ganze zentralisiertes
landet es bei uns irgendwo in der türkei
im innenministerium bei der
polizeibehörde
viele sagen dass das eine möglichkeit
ist für jedermann einfach jemand anderen
zu denunzieren
sprich dann nicht über ein strafdelikt
wie diebstahl sondern es geht vielleicht
darum dass man sagt dieser mann hat sich
kritisch gegenüber präsident erdogan
geäußert und wird deswegen hier gemeldet
mit facebook postet ein was dazu gehört
also das sensation diese kritik ist
vollkommen unberechtigt und ich kenne
keinen einzigen der welt
regierungskritischen post jemals ein
problem mit der typischen staat bekommen
hat gibt es nicht
und diese sehr alt und asche ist
überzeugt dass die türkische justiz vom
staat unabhängig handele und faire
verfahren garantieren
das treffe auch auf bekannte fälle von
journalisten wie mash alle toll und
emmys uk zu wenn der denn es wird ja
selber eine tube fliegt in den kandil
bergen
danach trifft er sich noch nach was ich
in der türkei mit verschiedenen freier
mann verschieben weil das kleinste licht
ist weil das reisefreiheit ist ja hat im
nachgang verschiedenste kontakte mit
personen die in der türkei als
terroristen gelten ein fragwürdiges
rechtsverständnis und für regimekritiker
kann die anzeige mittels der
umstrittenen app in der türkei zu großen
problemen führen
sebald und asch sich sogar von der
deutschen justiz bestätigt
bundestagsabgeordnete hatten wegen der
app strafanzeige gestellt aber der
generalbundesanwalt hat von der
einleitung eines ermittlungsverfahrens
abgesehen es gebe keine zureichenden
tatsächlichen anhaltspunkte
[Musik]
und das obwohl der deutsche
verfassungsschutz in einem bericht warnt
die fgm mobil diene als mögliches
instrument der denunziation zurück in
berlin
hier sind wir mit serien dagdelen
verabredet auch die linken politikerin
fühlt sich bedroht
wir schauen uns gemeinsam eine
pressekonferenz von 2018 in ankara an
auf die frage eines journalisten ob
kühlen anhänger im ausland mit
entführung rechnen müssten drohte
sprecher erdogans ganz unverhohlen
es kann jederzeit überall alles mögliche
passieren unser präsident hat hierzu
ganz klare anweisungen gegeben unsere
einheiten arbeiten auch bei diesem thema
außerordentlich professionell natürlich
eine sprache der mafia der hier benutzt
ganz klare drohung nicht nur die
wenigsten er sagt zwei gitarristen aber
er meint natürlich alle kritiker alle
anders denken dann werden hier ganz
deutlich bedroht auch serien datalan
lebt zeitweise unter polizeischutz sie
kritisiert die bundesregierung dafür
dass sie nicht endlich deutlicher wird
im umgang mit erdogan
ich denke dass die politik der
bundesregierung eine politik der
ermutigung ist für die türkische
regierung
der türkische staatspräsident andrew
denkt handelt und fühlt wie ein pater
aus der organisierten kriminalität
deutschland unternehme dagegen nichts
die bundesregierung hat eine enge
zusammenarbeit mit erdogan
sie möchte nämlich die lokale
unterallgäu in der nato halten koste es
was es wolle man nimmt auch in kauf die
gefahr für die öffentliche sicherheit in
deutschland weil man das netzwerk des
türkischen präsidenten in deutschland
duldet einfach und ihn gewähren lässt
was sagt das bundesinnenministerium zu
den vorwürfen
es weist sie zurück und teilt uns mit
dass das bmi der ausbildungsaktivitäten
und übergriffe von angehörigen oder mit
helfern türkischer geheimdienste in
deutschland gegen kritiker des erdogan
regimes sehr ernst nimmt und solche
aktivitäten keinesfalls duldet
der geheimdienstexperte schmidt-eenboom
sieht das anders
die bundesregierung duldet auf der
ganzen ebene die starts terroristischen
aktivitäten der türken in der
bundesrepublik deutschland das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat eindeutig
festgeschrieben dass die bundesrepublik
eine schutzpflicht gegenüber allen hier
lebenden menschen hat ganz gleich
welcher nationalität und diese
bundesregierung verletzt fortgesetzt
diese schutzpflicht erdogan kritiker
sind auch in deutschland nicht sicher
der türkische präsident benutzt den
türkischen geheimdienst um seine gegner
zu verfolgen und zu bedrohen und viele
seiner anhänger hierzulande stellen sich
in seinen dienst die bundesregierung
geht dagegen nicht entschlossen genug
vor entgegen demokratischer prinzipien
[Musik]